pam i have a very important job for you
today
i thought we were just having fun at the
beach we are we
are all participating in mandatory fun
activities fun tivities
and there is a special secret prize for
the winner
yes funtivities all right find a cozy
spot
everybody settle in
okay everybody up
circle around let us play some games
okay who's hungry no no no do not touch
the food please not yet
that is our next event a hot dog eating
contest
for those of you who are curious the
world record is
54 and one half hot dogs
wow and you know what i personally have
cooked up
enough so that each and every one of you
could break that record so shoot for the
stars okay
all right the team that eats the most
hot dogs in 10 minutes will be declared
the winner
on your mark get set can i have the
turkey
no i have the only one i claimed it
ready
turkey is a healthy meat yeah
please let's just okay it's very
important that you all try to eat as
many hot dogs as you can
on your mark get set
eat is there any mustard no mustard no
mustard just
eat it eat it phyllis dip it in the
water so it'll slide down your gullet
more easily
come on the winner gets a big big pride
i can't say
you can't say or you can't pronounce it
the winner gets regional manager's
salary for a year and a sebring
and the feeling that they are making a
difference in the world can we just take
those first two things the winner of
today
gets my job
okay i'm interviewing for a job at
corporate
and they're only interviewing a handful
of people and i'm the most qualified and
i'll probably get it
all right you're leaving i didn't want
to tell anybody i didn't want to cast a
paul
over our fun beach day but you know what
i don't know who to recommend because
frankly nobody's stepping up
i am so hungry do you expect me to
believe that you truly making your
recommendations
on this basis word there we go
let's see it i would rather work for an
upturned room with a bucket for a head
than work for somebody else in this
office besides myself
game on come on four seconds come on
three
two one stop you're eating
and the winner is andy bernard with 14
hot dogs one came up
13 hot dogs everybody oh
nobody told me we're gonna have hot dogs
come camping with us
it'll be really fun you'll be away from
chris you can brainstorm
i'll give you first dibs on s'mores
okay that sounds fun here is our
official retreat schedule it divides our
time
evenly between work and play come on
everybody let's hustle
let's get to the brainstorming great
attitude ron
i just want to get the work over as soon
as possible so i can do some fishing
fishing relaxes me it's like yoga
except i still get to kill something
all right i call this wonderful spot you
didn't bring a tent
well i don't really go camping ever
jerry so i'm not gonna spend 150
on a tent just gonna sleep on the floor
it's called the ground
when it's outside i mean yes my daughter
might think she is old enough to be
sexually active with her boyfriend but
i'm sorry 16. that
that just seems too young to be on birth
control you know i was 24
when gail took my virginity would say we
just stand here
in silence and think of ideas
for projects you know what i should do i
should lead
a teen abstinence workshop
that might be incredibly effective
welcome
to the quiet corn i'm elsa clack
breakfast is served between 5 30 and 6
15
a.m what if we sleep to a normal hour
well that would be very rude of you
may i take your breakfast order we have
hard-boiled eggs
homemade tomato slices with dry seed and
leek jam
and your choice of german muffin
the [ __ ] is a german muffin
[Music]
yeah she died like 20 minutes after that
is everyone packed for the 28th annual
tri-state police officers convention
i hear bill powell's giving a lecture on
advances in appellate court
e-filing techniques talk about can't
miss yeah we don't really go for the
talks
we're more interested in the
extracurriculars
fart five of course rochester has much
to offer in that sphere
for instance it's famed thermometer
museum thermometer museum
and no thank you here's what uh we are
all about
one free hotel rooms i get to sleep in a
bed by myself
no wife no kids just terry starfishing
on a cal king
two a huge hall full of cool police tech
last year i got to try out a heat ray
three the buffalo pd always throws an
insane party last year amy got so drunk
she jumped a police horse into
the pool hate drink amy is an equestrian
and she's real bad at it
jake this party is insane forget bonnie
ray it's like the video to love shaq in
here
this is the greatest
oh god it's my new partner you guys are
texting each other now it sends alerts
holt left his room he's on his way here
oh we got to get everyone out the
hallway
all right be quiet everybody be quiet
they're not listening to you
where's amy she's great at shushing wait
all these dum-dums are under 35.
let's use the wasp that'll hurt my young
little ears so much
come on
attention our boss is headed this way
everyone has to clear the hallway right
now
wow she is great at shushing i know
she's like a librarian
me like a sexy librarian no a regular
one
everyone you will go in the rooms and
you will go right now
don't make me count to three
hey captain what's up uh which room is
sergeant jeffords oh terry's in here
with
me and amy i'm just having a low key
night watching house hunters
international this orthodontist wants to
live in panama with his strangely old
wife and won't say why can i talk to him
oh let me check
yeah now he's asleep can i help you with
something i'm concerned that my
presentation isn't uh
jazzy enough to compete with jefferies
he's such a showman
i'm thinking about augmenting the graphs
with um
color sir i know i'm debasing myself
anyway
give this to jeffords he's the artist
i'd like him to choose the um
color yes all right no time to turn in
nighty night okay
he's gone now i just got to wait for
k-13 to give us the all-clear
yeah i wouldn't hold your breath dumb
robot probably roll into the stairwell
that's why i shouldn't be best friends
with this team
k-13 says we are g-2-g amy this shush is
lifted
[Applause]
[Music]
listen [ __ ] up buttercup i know exactly
what you need
ladies lunch huh you
me whoever not glenn um
yeah no i'm not really in the mood come
on
we can gab and dish and talk about our
periods your red zone usually starts on
the 24th right
is that something i'm supposed to know i
am the worst friend
yeah you are
okay cheyenne marcus brett
peter go okay i would
bang marcus marry brett
and kill beau's mom no cheyenne
she's not an option that's not the game
i don't care she sucks
um okay glenn garrett
and darren okay obviously i'd kill glenn
um probably just like slit his throat or
tear him limb for limb
uh then i married darren and i've
already garrett so i guess him again
no no really i have
i had to erase the security cameras
[Music]
la la
up
[Applause]
nice